so I've just decided I want to roll back
and just make some different choices on
this review so kind of a bit of a follow
up to Bandersnatch because I've now seen
it a couple more times and I've got an I
got myself a flowchart and have seen all
the endings including what I think I
would consider to be the proper ending
and since I am gonna be talking about it
in this fashion I'm gonna put the
spoiler warning right up front I mean at
this point he's been out long enough I
think most people who care about it have
already seen it but if you haven't I
would like if you want something a
little more spoiler friendly go check
out my earlier review about my first
experience watching it so a couple
things have happened since then first
thing that happened was I watched it
with my partner Liz and let it let her
make the choices funnily enough she made
almost all the same ones that I did
including like the innocuous ones at the
front end about what cereal and what
music to listen to like to the point
that it was starting to annoy her she
would make a decision and then go wait
what did you pick and I tell her it it
was the same thing she go dang it oh
that was a that was kind of interesting
um I saw a couple of new things on that
view with her but it was mostly similar
stuff and it was WOW watching with her
that I pulled up the flow chart and sort
of saw how you know something's coming
circle around in a bit of a cul-de-sac
where you know you get these choices but
if you've gone this one way it's all
good so like if you follow and like I
said there's gonna be spoilers so like
if you follow Colin instead of go visit
dr. Haynes that put you off and kind of
this cul-de-sac where you know you can
make these choices of do you take that
do you accept the acid refuse the acid
whatever but it just kind of puts you in
this little loop that you can dance
around until you you know go back to an
earlier
earlier decision see dr. Haines instead
and sort of seeing it broken down like
that I and I expect it might happen for
some people it kind of breaks the spell
a little bit seeing it charted it out
but only initially at least for me sort
of seeing that made me go oh okay and
having now gone through and gotten all
the interns and gotten what I consider
to be the proper ending which for me I
consider the five-star ending to be the
proper ending because it's got you've
the most proud buttons on the whole
thing and it kind of feels like it also
makes a very clear statement of intent
for what this thing was because there's
been the weird debate to me it's weird
debate like online between is this a
game or is this a movie now I don't
think it's weird that people are having
a hard time calling that I just find it
weird that as many people feel the need
to classify it as are jumping in on this
that's a little weird to me I mean for
my part I don't really care it's a
hybrid it's not that far from like a
walking simulator style video game it's
it's a blend of interactivity and
narrative that straddles the line so
when you try and force it to say no
decide what side of the line you're on I
don't know who that benefits or why we
do that but so coming back to the
five-star ending which I said I would
consider to be the proper ending and I
think that mainly has to do with a
couple of things the first is is that
you sort of have that bit from Colin
talking about the illusion of choice
which is it helped me to hear like I I
guess I think intellectually I kind of
knew that but I'm sort of hearing a lot
going yeah there's only so much you can
actually let the viewer decide on
because if you let them choose literally
anything then you can't actually tell a
story you can't you can't push them down
narrative
that ends properly or makes any kind of
sense so you have to you do have to
funnel their choices into certain things
and some of the choices that you give
them ultimately don't matter sort of
things there are things that you can do
to guide them to the certain choices
like I I would be willing to bet that
especially having not having gone the
other way on it now that the vast
majority of people when presented with
the option to create the game at Tucker
soft or to have Collin I'm sorry not
call it to have Stefan do it at home I
would bet the vast majority of people
accepted the offer and the the narrative
seems to be designed with the intention
that that's what you're gonna do at the
very least on your first time going
through so there seems to be a certain
kind of understanding of psychology of
like what if we structure it correctly
most people will choose this and then
for the folks who don't we're gonna make
it very clear now that wasn't good let's
loop back and go yet now for people who
wanted a much grand or more branching
experience I can see what that would be
frustrating where ultimately you know
while there are I think I don't know it
was like 9 or 11 or something like that
like endings quote-unquote some of them
are very very quick and like don't are
don't get proper closure and I can
understand why some people would feel a
certain amount of annoyance with that
and like I honestly I can flat-out of
sympathize because I remember when
multiple endings like to video games
first started becoming a thing and in
most instances that I've encountered
them I haven't liked them the reason
being that generally you just get a
bunch of slightly different weak endings
but like any one of those endings if
that was all you got like you wouldn't
accept that you'd be like that's not a
good ending or that's too quick or
that's not satisfying but we like we
were expected to accept it just because
there were so many of them and
I for me at least the experience of this
does dodge that problem I think
partially because of the meta-narrative
going on I think also especially now
that I've seen the 5-star ending you
know which has that and I think the
other reason I feel like calling that
the proper ending is it has sort of the
during the credits extra moments that
black mirror tends to do in in some of
its episodes so that as a result also
felt more like a like a black mirror
finish so but I'm just saying all that
to say like I get why some people might
be frustrated with the experience
especially if they thought that they
were gonna have more control and but
that's that's always kind of the thing
with these sorts of things like how much
control can you actually grant someone
before you just lose complete and utter
sense of the narrative that's being told
so that kind of brings me to the
question of can this ever work again
because I would argue it does work here
can it ever work again I honestly don't
know my inclinations is not really not
this well and I kind of touched on this
briefly during my previous review of
this thing but here's my way of thinking
like if you're my age then choose your
own adventure books or a thing when you
were in grade school so it if you
remember those at all how many people
like remember liking the actual stories
like not the experience of reading it
but like the narrative they're not
they're not particularly memorable some
of the endings you get are memorable but
a memorable moment a memorable ending is
not the same as a memorable narrative
with characters and arcs and you know
emotional impact the narratives were
very were very stripped down very
basically very generic very
dysfunctional they got the job done to
buoy the gimmick
was choose-your-own-adventure and that
is the thing choose-your-own-adventure
by its nature is a gimmick and i think
you can get away with that in a book a
little bit more partly because it's a
lot cheaper to write in print a book
than it is to produce something like
this because i my suspicion is that this
was probably very successful for Netflix
we'll never know for certain because
Netflix doesn't release its exact
viewing numbers but I suspect this did
well for them but I would be very
shocked if they see this kind of success
repeated because well first of all like
the eye I would imagine the amount of
work gone into this must have been
maddening to try and sketch this out to
even come up with what they did you know
regardless of what do you think they
completely pulled it off or not the
logistics of this must have been a
nightmare and you know trying to get all
that done and have a story that feels
like it's worth telling and and have the
gimmick be enjoyable that's a lot to ask
of anything and I mentioned before that
I think this is probably the best story
that you're gonna be able to tell with
this gimmick and I stand by that not
necessarily like the best experience you
could ever have but definitely the best
story I would be very shocked if anyone
else's that actually got a rung a
narrative out of this that was and
really any better than this because in
the nature of the gimmick does force you
to either give so much freedom that
everything has to be loosey-goosey and
interchangeable can change in at a
moment's notice or is so rich is so
restrictive in how few choices it gives
that the gimmick becomes pointless and I
think a good way around that and what
Bandersnatch does is to go meta with it
is to have the fact that someone
externally is making choices is actually
part of the narrative itself but having
now done that with basically the first
thing designed specifically for Netflix
to do that some people just pointed out
to me the my
the minecraft story mode thing is on
Netflix that already did that but that
was a video game first they just took
the story components and put them on so
I'm not counting that is the same thing
this was built from the ground up to be
Netflix streaming so for like for their
first go on this to immediately
deconstruct the thing they were doing as
they were premiering it I've said in the
past when you deconstruct something you
basically you break it and it doesn't
really work again after you do that and
I'm not sure what more there is to do
with this
entire concept of
choose-your-own-adventure streaming
besides just bolting a gimmick onto
things but the thing is unlike mutton
generally gimmicks are just something
that's there and they don't have a
massive impact on the narrative so like
3d is a gimmick hey I consider IMAX to
be a gimmick a very pretty looking
gimmick sure but it's a gimmick people
will build you know their films around
it but ultimately even without it you
can spear Ian Syd as a film as a story
the choose-your-own-adventure thing
doesn't quite work like that I do feel
it is still a gimmick and that it's just
a novelty being bolted on to grab
attention but it does force you to
fundamentally change what it is you're
doing from the ground up which makes it
a really difficult thing to do an even
harder thing to do well and I'd be
really surprised if this actually
becomes like a serious trend I expect we
get we'll get a few more folks we'll try
it we'll probably get a few more this
year I expect we'll get a few next year
because they'll be you know people and
show makers or what have you who see
this this year and go I bet I could do
something that they'll work on it
through all this year it'll come out
next year but I will bet money that once
we're out of 2020 this sort of thing is
going to be a
rarity if not just kind of dead in the
water for the amount of work that's
gonna be involved versus the returns
you're gone that most of these places
are gonna end up getting back but we'll
see I still enjoyed it I still liked
Bandersnatch it's yeah it is an
experience it does straddle that line
and yeah yeah I I think this was this
was a solid piece of work from Black
Mara I thought it was a kind of a cool
experiment I don't think I need to see
this gimmick ever done again doc so
Bandersnatch sort of a more thorough
thoughts on and now that I've
experienced pretty much everything that
it has to offer so any additional
thoughts you want to share that maybe
you didn't leave on my last video if you
even saw my last video on it whatever
they are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about a whole bunch
of stuff you can do because it's buttons
and links including went to the patreon
if you are the generous type every
little bit helps it's cliche to say it
but it is actually true but if you don't
want to there's a whole bunch of other
links down there you can press you don't
want to click on any of them that's okay
too because at the end of the day you
are the council I just run the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]